when when we had a chance to connect I
think you if I'm not mistaken you maybe
saw a post on Twitter that you liked
about our some of our work and Outreach
in um in Africa across Kenya
and Uganda Nairobi and Kampala you I
think you had saw one of the posts and
we connected and we reached out and um
you're very generous to lend your
platform to help us kind of spread the
word about what we're dealing with the
uh the gifted chess initiative but
basically
um get the chess um is an issue that
really wants to spread the gift of Chess
um all over the world we think chess is
the greatest game in the world that has
incredible benefits
um and like when I say about the
benefits of Chess it's not only the
educational benefits and the the way
that chess helps you think strategically
and planning and all of that it's also
the opportunity in Chester great game
that connects each of us I'm sure on
this stream itself there's people from
tons of different countries and walks of
life and backgrounds and and Chester
provides us an amazing Community where
we can meet and play and interact with
so many different
um people and just enjoy just humanity
and so they get to chess is all about
giving out chess sets to um just to the
world as a gift and allowing those
chesses to create opportunities for
other people I'm glad to be here
supporting gift of Chess uh you know
it's obviously you guys are uh doing
God's work for chefs for sure it's uh
you know all of us Grand Masters we're
just all in it for ourselves and uh you
guys are much more selfless and I'm
really glad that
you're doing what you can to have trust
make a difference in all over the world
and in communities that have not
necessarily been exposed to it as much
as they should have been I'm currently
the Global Outreach director and I
started reaching out first in Kenya fast
spreading there we've already received
our 1000 sets
which we've started Distributing to the
major slums of Nairobi we've reached out
to
three major slums of Nairobi and the
kids are very grateful some of them have
never seen chessboard before and we're
grateful for the gift of just to have
given them this opportunity so
personally I'd love to thank you guys
for the great work the great works you
do ras the gift of Chase under believing
in humanity to a point of action
yeah so personally I've come to see
what the gift of chess can do yeah
through our partnership with just his
loans and
um with the visit of uh impact coaching
Network and the gift of chairs we
implemented
um chess as part of the curriculum of
the school so currently we have
225 kids enrolled and all the 225 kids
are learning chess education a couple
months ago what happened was Russ had
reached out and there was a similar
which I got offered to play in New York
I accepted and okay the event was quite
great it was amazingly organized and I
had a lot I had a lot of fun so I I love
this initiative also that the gift of
Chess is supporting to give out chess
sets to kids around the world we go I'm
expecting I've seen pictures of
McClurkin
you know I I've seen
on a screen what it would look like but
when I got there you know people were
warm I didn't feel unsafe I didn't feel
anything other than
that other than I I expected to be doing
good there and I expected to to add
something to the lives of the children
there that that wasn't there before been
invited to to uh kick it kick off the
event by speaking uh with b-day they
give me uh giving uh the gift chance to
all of us that that opportunity to to to
Really uh just show our appreciation and
get the word out what we're trying to
accomplish uh through globally and right
here in America uh so yeah that's one
thing that we have gotten accomplished
this is the first time at one of our
facilities prison that we're able to
play online chess championships so going
forward
it may open up the doors to do it more
times for most of us here we're in
different parts of the world you know
and um the one thing that brings us all
together I brings this all together is
chess in a universal language and I mean
I just want to tell people that
um we have a vision to use chess as a
tool right to help create you know an
intellectual identity for some of the
children that live in Muslim communities
right and to us you know in our own
privileged my thing is just a fun game
that we can just play every now and then
and enjoy but to a child you know in the
slums you know living in this important
conditions you know you could mean
everything to them and you know the
level of confidence that it gives them
that they are able to also show
intellectual capacity for something
[Music]